well it's been a while last time my uh
last time I worked with you I think you
were based up in New York
um
you had some different people on your
team we had a lot of fun what so people
have been connecting deeply with our
guests um they where
bring yourself into the room a little
bit here what is what Simon been working
on where I hear are you living in La now
you've got it your life has changed a
little bit life has changed my life has
changed a lot actually
um uh uh so my sister and her family
live in Los Angeles and so when kovitz
struck
um I thought you know what I'll go to La
for a couple months while covid you know
blows over that'll be nice weather's
nice and I'm still here
so I guess I live in Los Angeles now
um
you know I I I'm a great believer that
the world is made up of balance
um and for anything good that happens to
us it comes at a cost always and I'd
like to consider what that cost is but
when something bad happens to us there's
also
opportunity or lessons or something and
I'm I'm very I sort of made a practice
out of always trying to keep the balance
so I don't take good for granted and bad
I always try and get something out of it
and covered was such a shock to the
system
the the opportunity was huge I mean
total reinvention if you wanted it and
for our business it was total
reinvention but for me it gave him an
opportunity to sit and breathe
um you know uh I and I think many people
in this room can relate you know that
we're on a hamster wheel for our careers
and we think that we're setting the
speed of the hamster wheel by how fast
we're running and the the hard lesson
that I that I learned is I'm just
running to keep up
and for a period of time covet stopped
the wheel
and I got off
and then I got to look around and say do
I want to get back on that wheel or is
there something else I want to do
um and so there was a ton of
introspection I I'm I've grown up a lot
to be honest
um uh and I worked hard I had that time
to to do it
um and I also decided how I want to
spend the rest of my life
um I'm very very very proud of the work
that I have done and the work that I do
and spreading a message and challenging
traditional Notions of how business
works and how we can change that uh you
know my Nemesis Jack Welch
um uh
but the question is is like like I'm
proud of that and it has its own
momentum and I'm a great believer in
measuring uh success not by hitting
absolutes but by counting momentum and
that's for us individually as well as
businesses
um uh and then it's much easier to
maintain momentum and so when you when
um when I first started hearing about
people are like you've gotta you gotta
you know as we're getting into this
purpose thing and why you've got to meet
Simon he's incredible blah blah blah and
it was you know you'd written these
books my favorite was leaders he'd last
um that just the concept alone is so
true
um starting with why there was this
meteoric rise where everybody watched a
15-minute video yeah you know just as
simple as a TED Talk somewhere yeah yeah
and and uh did you know that I mean did
you sense that was going to happen or
were you just kind of out riffing on
your thoughts and something took hold
I'd been giving that talk for are you a
little inside baseball now okay so I've
been giving I've been giving that talk
for three years and the shortest I ever
did it was an hour
and wow when they invited me to do the
tedx
uh I was like yeah fine they're like do
you want to do rehearsal I'm like no
it's the same content I've been doing it
for three years like I know it and like
the night before I was like I've never
done it in 18 minutes and like then the
Panic wow uh
but I figured I'll just leave some stuff
out
I just had a you just had a piece of
paper and a couple searches so it was
funny because right before I was
supposed to speak and it was only like
50 people in the room right before I was
supposed to speak I realized that my old
introduction for an hour-long talk was
like eight minutes I'm like I can't use
up eight minutes on an introduction so I
like went for a walk around the block to
try and come up with a new introduction
that was just like 30 seconds
um but yeah I I I didn't expect it to do
what it did of course not I mean it's
like winning the lottery you know uh I
never expected it to do what it did but
it makes sense to me it's a deeply human
message it I knew from the three years
that I've been giving that talk that
people related to it so I understand it
but I also think it was timing you know
I came out at a time where tedx was a
relatively new thing and there weren't
that many of them now there's thousands
and thousands of them a year I don't
know if it would pop the same way today
as it did yeah so I think I got lucky
with the timing Leaders Eat Last start
with start with why
um and then
um and then that that sort of created
the this whole thing and I've always
felt like and on the one hand you've got
you you kind of access revolutionary
thoughts and you know change you you I
think you believe
um that America is a great place but it
needs to change corporate America
capitalism is a is a great thing but
it's not gonna it's not gonna make it in
its current if it keeps going the Jack
Welch kind of kind of mentality that
yeah win at all costs
um and and so since then you've been
working on a new body of work the
infinite game
um and and more recently what how do you
summarize sort of where your thinking
has evolved from purpose to more than
that yeah I mean my work is all uh it's
all a journey so it all builds upon the
last thing like they stand alone as
separate ideas but it all builds upon
the last thing of course
um and uh the infinite game I'm obsessed
with it to be honest um the original
definition was proposed by a theologian
and and uh uh philosopher by the name of
Dr James cars back in the mid 80s and
I'd known about Carson's work for years
and had read his original book finite
infinite games and it's a kooky little
philosophy book
um but I realize it's starting to impact
the way I thought and for those who
don't know I'll give you the quick
synopsis so there are two types of games
there are finite games in their infinite
games a finite game is defined as known
players fixed rules and an agreed upon
objective football baseball there is
always a beginning middle and an end and
if there were if there was a winner
necessarily they have to be losers right
then you have infinite games infinite
games are defined as known and unknown
players
which means anyone can join at any time
and you don't necessarily know who all
the other players are
the rules are changeable which means
every player can play however they want
and the objective is to perpetuate the
game to stay in the game as long as
possible we're players in infinite games
every day of Our Lives whether we know
it or not like you're not going to win
your marriage right you can't be number
one in your marriage number two for sure
but never number one
um uh nobody wins education you can come
in first for the finite amount of time
you're at school where we agreed upon
the time frame and we agreed upon the
metrics called grades but nobody wins
education nobody wins health care nobody
wins career and definitely no company is
declared the winner of business right
but if you listen to the language of so
many leaders it becomes abundantly clear
that they don't know the game they're
playing in they talk about being number
one being the best or beating their
competition
based on what based upon what agreed
upon metrics objectives or time frames
and this is a problem because when we
play with a finite mindset in an
infinite game when you play to win in a
game that has no Finish Line
there are predictable and consistent
outcomes the big ones being the decline
of trust the decline of cooperation the
decline of innovation like when Circuit
City went bankrupt Best Buy didn't win
anything right all that happened is they
lost one of the players other players
fill the Gap and they have to learn to
reinvent because now Amazon's a new
competitor and now they have to
completely change the way they want to
play otherwise they'll fall out of the
game as well
um and so this was profound for me
because when I started to apply that
definition to my work and the business
World it became abundantly clear that
starting in the late 70s early 80s our
nation was the way we we distorted
capitalism like Adam Smith capitalism
that made this country great and made it
what it as wealthy as it is and gave it
such remarkable influence and we're the
most Innovative Innovative nation in the
world almost almost every great
invention that has affected the planet
Earth came from us right
um which is astonishing modern modern
inventions clearly mathematics wasn't
ours
um uh
um
but you start to see the dismantling
of that infinite mindset that Adam Smith
and Thomas Jefferson and all these folks
embraced
uh Thomas Jefferson was a huge fan of
Adam Smith
um and you start to see this more
finite-mindedness the rise of
shareholders Supremacy
where an ex a disinterested external
constituency becomes more important than
a customer or an employee which is like
a coach of a team trying to make a great
team by taking advice from
fair-weathered fans and ignoring the
needs of players I mean that's kind of
what that is
um you see the rise of things like using
mass layoffs on a regular basis to
balance the books we were profitable
just not as profitable as we had
promised so all of you lose your job
oh no you've been great it's not a
meritocracy you know and you start to
see the steady drumbeat over the course
of the past 30 40 years where we have
actually been dismantling
the awesomeness of American capitalism
I'm a die hard capitalist just not the
form that we've we've we've created and
it's very very recent it's very very
modern and Jack Welch is the poster
child for that form of capitalism you
know Gordon Gekko but he's a fictional
character
um uh and and we've seen the result
which we've seen massive backlash we've
seen the decline in the life of a
lifespan of companies right it went from
60 years to now which is 17 years the
average lifespan of a company
um we've seen declines in Innovation
we've seen disengagement from employees
we've seen lack of loyalty from
employees we you know we complain about
young people that you know they're not
loyal and they Bounce from job well
think how they grow up they watch their
parents get laid off through no fault of
their own because of this insane system
um so why should they be loyal I don't
blame them
um and we see we see uh the results we
see increases in stress and
disengagement and malaise and depression
and anxiety these are all relate the
great resignation which if we want to go
down that rabbit hole all related
so um I think there's a massive
opportunity for forward-thinking
companies because GE and and those
companies had massive influence in the
direction of
capitalism because they were so wealthy
others just copied them right not
because they were good but because they
had short-term success other but others
went well it's working for them and
because the whole system's an upheaval
there's massive opportunity for for
newcom for a new company there is no
Heir Apparent
to redirect what the future of American
Business will look like
in addition GE was the leadership
Factory for that model if you had GE on
your resume you could go anywhere and
you were a senior executive you can be
our CEO right it's the number of CEOs
that came from GE was disproportionate
um there has been no error apparent for
the modern leadership Factory for
the the the the what capitalism should
be for infinite-minded capitalism so I
think uh the opportunity is available to
this because I like to think that it's
in this room something a lot of people
don't know is uh Jack Welch put on a
full court press to buy this company
um he uh he he did he put on his A-game
and um
the my grandmother
um her sister didn't want to and you
know they didn't really know why they
just didn't quite feel right it was a
ton of money you know everything daddy
did so to speak was coming to fruition
and man what are we going to do in this
new world but they there's this picture
where um Jack Welch is like giving a big
thumbs up like with my with my
grandmother and she's she has she had a
look about her she was looking at him
sideways and it was a very prophetic
because I think he thought everything
was done but she was like yeah I would
love a copy of that picture yeah I'll
get it for you it's it's a great picture
and her her facial expression
reflects what what you're saying about
that mindset but it was this you know I
think what she said was in her mind and
she may have told me this um daddy
wouldn't have liked this
um you know this it was never about
money it was about employees and it was
about thanking people that got us here
and it was about a relationship between
you know yes we own this thing but we're
we owe something to you know the folks
we started it with and and um and uh
you know and that's that's always been
the mindset and so we we're here we are
now in this saying that I'm I'm just
kind of thinking out loud here but
some of the things that are frustrating
all of us frustrating me is like this
sense of
control and facts and what we know to be
true yeah is like Challenge and it's so
weird to think that facts are not facts
or what is a fact I actually got into
this conversation unfortunately over
Thanksgiving with my mother-in-law she
had a couple glasses of wine but she I
said you have to admit that you have you
can't you know you have to
you have to admit that a fact exists and
she said you'll have to prove that to me
I'm like okay we can't I can't do this
this is yeah beyond my pay grade but you
know so vaccines yeah
you know oh you know this horrible thing
is happening
um we're all out of the office we can't
come back to the office without vaccines
I mean you can't have like some people
that are mysteriously not vaccinated
some people that are and you wear like a
bracelet and I'm good and they're not
you just can't it's kind of like smoking
if you're walking around secondhand
smoking you're getting other people sick
yeah it's just not fair yes it's your
right to do so I guess as a human but
it's not you're right like sort of in
the workplace so we have to do this
thing so
are we all agreed sure now you start to
tell employees there's a large group of
people that are like I'll be damned you
know how dare you this this company is
all about it all about empowerment it's
all about you know um telling me it's my
choice you're giving me the power to do
what I want now you're telling me I have
to do this or I'm fired yeah we're like
you're not fired you're it's just we
hope you agree that the world will never
get back to normal unless all of us jump
in and and and and and be safe and and
more importantly it's not about you it's
about spreading it to others and you
have to stop it you have to stop it with
your body and there's no reason to
believe it's dangerous you know all that
and
um yeah but what about theirs have you
read verse I went on there and you know
there's there's somebody who said they
took it and they died the next day and
I'm like well if they died the next day
how would they put that on bears bears
is an open mic there's no there's no
scientific validity to it but everybody
has their version yeah everybody's
arguing there's no way to win the
argument yeah so who's in control are we
able to tell employees to come to work
are we asking them
uh you know what it's a frustrating time
and every person in this room has been
through the frustration yeah there was a
cartoon in
I think it was a New Yorker cartoon
uh and a flight attendant on the plane
said uh is there a doctor or anyone
who's done their own research aboard
please
um
a little I thought
maybe maybe it's just me
um
uh
so okay that's let's jump into this
um
there's a lot there's a lot to unpack
there obviously
um there are two thoughts that come to
mind one is about control and one is
about
and it goes back to finite mindedness
which is our nation
over indexed on finite mindedness for 30
40 years and it affected everything it
affected business affected politics it
affected military it affect every aspect
of life did it change with the with
Vietnam you mentioned that a long time
ago before you wrote the book it was
like we we invaded we were going to win
and beat them we had completely they
weren't trying to beat us they just
wanted to live past us and there was no
City to take over you couldn't go to
Berlin and have this all right over the
Ho Chi Minh city was empty so so what
Alex is referring to in in the book I
have this opening story to make the case
which is in Vietnam
over the course of that 10-year War
uh we won almost every major battle we
fought most people don't know that we
actually won most most the battles we've
fought uh most major battles uh over the
course of those 10 years we lost 58 000
soldiers and Marines they lost uh over 3
million
and so it raises a very interesting
question if you win the battles and you
decimate your enemy how do you lose the
war
and so that's one of the things that got
me interested in in this definition of
the infinite game which is clearly
there's more than one definition of
winning and losing
um uh and in this case America was
fighting with a finite mindset in an
infinite game they were fighting to win
and the Vietnamese were fighting to
survive
and they would fight to the very last
person if necessary and a finite player
who's playing with a finite mindset an
infinite game
where you're uh the other players are
playing with the right mindset will
always find themselves in Quagmire
always and the resource the the the
currency of an infinite game is Will and
resources resources obvious and business
it's money War it's money too
um but this will of the people remember
we left Vietnam because the will of the
people back home yeah and and will is
one of those things that's very often
forgotten companies think they're strong
when they're rich
Enron was rich GE was rich
G is a shadow of its former self you
know uh but what was the will of the
people you know when when when the
foundation shook did they abandon ship
for themselves or did they hunker down
and come together and our nation because
of this obsession with finite mindedness
for the past 30 40 years which means you
know a couple of generations were raised
with that mentality and they were told
that you will excel in at work and in
your career if you if you do this and
now they're the senior executives
um and uh uh operating under that
operating under that mentality that
trade so our nation double we we over
indexed rugged individualism
and we forgot cooperation you know
there's an entire section of the
Bookshop called self-help an industry by
the way that was invented in the 1970s
there's an entire industry there's an
entire section of the Bookshop called
self-help and there's no section in the
Bookshop called help others you know in
politics compromises become a dirty word
and the reality if you if you have been
if you are married or if you have a
relationship
um good luck with with trying to always
be right like compromises listening you
know give and take that's part of the
game for success and
um and businesses is a community a
company is a tribe and sometimes things
will go exactly your way and sometimes
they don't but there has to be this
general feeling that the company cares
about me as a human being that I'm
seeing that I'm heard that I'm
understood that I believe in the vision
that I want to advance the culture and I
and I believe and I fit the value set
and the value set fits me and I feel
like this is part of my personal
identity working here like when I say
the company's name and I say my name
they feel they feel that feels right
um and and we all know that within those
relationships that there's give and take
for management all the way on down
um and this goes back into control which
is we we are happy to give up control
when we feel that there is trust first
and I'll give you an extreme example
um so I had a conversation with a marine
a marine officer
and uh he was talking about
because the Marines are pretty amazing
as a culture they're pretty dynamic they
believe in Semper Gumby always flexible
you know we got a Marine in the audience
so they believe in sambergambi and they
encourage creativity they encourage
decision making at the front lines
um they and they they're very good at
building trust and and and and it's a
values-based organization right they
instill the values in their Marines
and all of that trust
and all of that flexibility builds to
something which is in a high stress
situation combat
it is all command and control the
officer says you do that and the Marine
just does it there is no question asked
and there's no pushback this is not the
time for well I'd like to share my ideas
about what you've proposed pick up land
low right now right it doesn't work that
way and the and the reason is is because
in high stress we need we need command
and control it's actually very very
important but it's done so with the
absolute undying belief that you're
making decisions with what you believe
is the best interest of the organization
the mission whatever it is and I accept
that sometimes you almost make mistakes
and that in in the case of combat could
cost people's lives and I accept that
because I believe that you still have
the best interests of this organization
more than yourself you're not sending me
to Harm's Way you're not leveraging the
trust and and the command for personal
gain you're doing it for the gain of us
and and
that is exactly the same in a well-run
organization which is you in good times
we we share the wealth we don't hoard
the wealth in good times we save money
that's amazing to me how many companies
give away all the money in Good Times
save that because not all times are good
right huge amounts of savings as well
reinvestment ignoring shareholders
short-term desires I have no desire to
make a 27 year old NLS rich and meet his
financial goals we have ours first one
of my one of I don't know if you know
Gary Ridge the CEO of WD-40 he had an
uncomfortable analyst call not for him
but for his analysts uh
uh one of his reporting one of his
quarterly calls the analyst said to him
uh you've missed your numbers
and Gary responded no I I missed your
numbers my numbers are fine
um
um uh
uh but in a company especially in a high
stress situation of which covet is one
of them and keeping the there there is
an element of I I'm gonna do this and
and you can't maintain command and
control for long periods of time because
then you break trust it's it's episodic
um and it's usually under high stress
um because that's the system
um and you've spent years building up
the trust and
um if people don't trust then it just
raises questions
um did they not fit our values maybe
maybe we accidentally hired people that
don't belong here so okay that's good to
know or maybe I need some more
leadership training at my middle
management levels because it's breaking
whatever it is or maybe Senior
Management needs to take a look at have
we been good at communicating or and Etc
et cetera is it circumstantial is it
situational it's complicated it's messy
and and the best companies are not
perfect they're constantly improving
everything they're doing is constant
proven like the best people aren't
perfect but they're in constant growth
mode it's exactly the same thing
um so and then the elements of control
also
um which you touched upon and I'm
fascinated by this element of control
can I just sort of yeah talk a little
bit about one of the ways I'm like a
wind-up toy I'll just keep going yeah
one of the ways I'm I'm I think about
control is so we used to have you'd have
a job description and somebody would
show up and say I like that roll here's
my resume it fits together and we say
okay we'll pay you right X and hopefully
you'll do these you know these things
and
um and uh love to have a great career
and all that and you know you come into
the office you know we see you yeah you
kind of do you play you do these things
it's an it's an expectation so now
you've said yes covet happens and now
we're on the other side of that and
we've told you to leave we sort of
expected that one day this would end I
mean I remember putting out a video so
this might last till the end of the
month right I think it was March April
uh you know this might last this could
go through the summer yeah let's go to
Labor Day it could go to December you
know we might go into this I was the
outlier by the way I predicted the end
of the summer really yeah yeah that was
the that was the outlier and then it
just kept going and now it's gone on so
long yeah that we don't really know what
lies on the other side and so I had this
extraordinary conversation it was just a
it was the first one I had it wasn't
that extraordinary it was just the first
time I experienced it but I was you know
I used to do the lunch uh you know I go
down to the cafeteria and we see people
and I'd sit down with somebody at lunch
and just chat and you know how are you
and uh all that so I I was missing that
I was recreating it on Zoom so you know
just to pick so and so in the I.T
department or so and so in sales and
just have a zoom call it's not quite the
same but you know I was like so how are
you doing you know I'm so excited it
looks like with the vaccines and
everything will be coming back and and
without it without thinking that he was
saying anything that was like concerning
to me he was like
well you know I've moved down to Saint
Pete and I was like Saint Pete like St
Petersburg Florida and he works in the
building with me I mean I see him all
the time and uh not in St Petersburg no
yeah I mean and and up in Dunwoody and I
was like so
that's amazing so are you uh do you live
there now or are you are you going to be
are you coming back here he said oh yeah
I mean I'll manage my time of course but
uh we have we have never been happy we
just took the plunge my whole family and
he was just like so thrilled with his
life and I'm like I'm so happy for you
but I'm like at scale I don't know what
this means
um you know we have a campus with like 8
000 uh people on it
um
we've never you know when we did when we
did um dress code we used to dress in
suits I mean coming to work in a suit
and then it was business casual what
does business casual mean can you wear
jeans uh what if they're ripped what if
they're frayed you know what if you
could see your underwear underneath and
there was all these like what if what if
what if and I think Goldman Sachs um had
a long book or as Morgan Stanley had a
long book it was like 70 pages long of
all the exceptions you know flesh
colored tights and it was like got
really weird JP Morgan said dress
appropriately right and I was like I
feel kind of like dressed appropriately
just I mean if you look weird your boss
should just tell you and yeah it
shouldn't be like we're gonna get sued
moment
um I I feel like you know this is the
same thing it's like work appropriately
but I hope we can all agree that
life is a live event you know yeah you
you there's nothing like being here with
with our colleagues there's no there's
nothing like um
you know a a a game a live you know
basketball or something is not the same
on Nintendo I mean it's cool but it's
not it's not as you just don't get that
same thing so
we want people to come back together we
want them to use their best judgment but
we don't know if they will and it all it
all just gets to control at some point
you're like listen you got to be in more
than half your time it has to be the
exception not the right the rule not the
exception or kind of thing but you can't
really do that because we're in a weird
place and and that translates to lots of
different parts of our life company
Barry waymiller calls it responsible
Freedom you know companies say we love
to give our people freedom and and they
say we give our people responsible
freedom and I love the word that they
add I love the way that they add
responsible before Freedom it doesn't
mean you can do whatever you want it
means that you know you can't just blow
a budget for someone's birthday you know
I mean you do we act responsibly um I
mean and you know what's responsible I
mean like I think we most people know
what that line is and sometimes there's
blocking tackles and corrections as you
said
um uh but I think one of the things
we're seeing you know is
um is there's been a general feeling in
the United States of lack of control and
control and the feeling of control is a
is a remarkable thing in how it affects
human beings
um there was some there were these
studies done in the
1970s in the UK called the Whitehall
studies
and they wanted these social scientists
want to understand this thing that they
labeled executive stress syndrome
right which the Assumption was the more
senior you get the more responsibility
you have the more impact your decisions
can make the more stress that that that
puts upon you so they did the study in
government in Whitehall because they
could control for variances in health
care because everybody got the same
um and here's what they discovered the
more senior you get your stress goes
down
yes you have more responsibility yes the
stakes are higher but you also have more
agency you get to decide how to spend
your day you get to have more control
over how you solve a problem and when
you're in the most Junior position you
have the least amount of agency because
somebody tells you what to do and you're
going to do it this way and there is no
creativity and there is no there is no
variability and it's the lack of control
that actually increases diabetes heart
disease and some cancers right I always
think it's amazing when you ask for a
meeting with somebody their immediate
assumption if they don't know you and
they're further down in the organization
as they're getting fired yeah you know
it's like no I'm giving you a bonus I
mean I just want to you know they're
like oh God thank God I thought you're
going to fire back why would I fire you
but you're raising that feeling of a
lack of control but you and you're
touching upon I think um a phenomenon
that has happened again I blame the past
30 40 years where you know people give
their entire lives to a company and then
get the proverbial gold watch there's an
entire generation that when we talk
about the gold watch they don't know
what we're talking about
uh because this doesn't exist anymore
and if you think about it and again
because of the the commonality the
frequency of of the use of layoffs as a
as a as a tool right we all I'm for
those who saw the better.com video I
don't know if you saw it it was
embarrassing you know the CEO made a
video that he played to employees that
over Zoom did he fired 900 people 900
people with a video saying if you're
unlucky enough to be seeing this video
and effectively effective in your your
terminated effective immediately you
know two weeks before Christmas and when
the CFO was interviewed about it he said
well we need to and I love this
terminology we need to Fortress the
balance sheet like this is why we should
not let CFOs like talk to the public
[Laughter]
uh
uh I was a wonderful man
properly
[Applause]
we love you baby it's very rare you must
it must it must be great here because
CFOs never get that kind of Applause
it's really wonderful
um uh
uh but the point the point is is is
um is what he what he Amplified
is that if you have your own business if
you're a small business owner you know
you're going to go out of business
months before like no small business
owner goes to work the one day thinking
everything's fine then the next day
there's nothing right it just doesn't
exist
but we now live in a society where
having a stable job with benefits could
end
tomorrow effective immediately is what
they were told not a meritocracy no
fault of my own the company's doing well
and so if you think about how twisted
that is that a quote unquote stable job
is actually not stable at all
and that stress sits with every single
employee you said we need to have a
meeting and fear is the first reaction
says something not necessarily about the
company but it says something about
business yeah and the way business and
Corporate America is viewed
um and when we don't feel like we have
control it manifests in crazy ways our
health is one of them but when when we
don't feel like we have control we look
to exert it in strange ways so companies
that have an excessive amount of office
politics
it's so I'll give you a real life
example this is a true this is a true
story there was a uh entry the person
was either an intern or entry level I
can't remember but it was beginning of
their career
uh and they had 11 interviews why why an
intern needs 11 interviews there's a
different conversation but they had 11
interviews including many Senior
Management and this is a big company
this is thousands of employees and then
finally they all loved the person they
all loved the candidate and then the CEO
interviewed them and the CEO decided I
don't like him and the kid didn't get
the job
that means 11 people were told
your opinion actually doesn't matter
and so this company was
fraught with politics because when I
can't even decide as a senior executive
to hire a freaking intern I'm going to
look to exert control any stupid little
way I can because I gotta feel like I
have control
January 6th is a you know there's a lot
of people who felt out of control
um and uh I read an article that it
disproportionately high percentage of
that population who who invaded the
capital that day were either currently
struggling with or have dealt with
significant financial trouble whether
it's debt or personal bankruptcy
disproportionately high right and coming
from a population that felt
disenfranchised by politics for the past
20 years
and so they there's looking to exert
control in crazy ways right
um and so uh uh the question is is what
can we as companies do to make people
feel
and have agency one of the ways is
accountability right which is you have
responsibility for this project
if it goes right I will give you credit
and if it goes wrong I will stand by you
and support you as you try and mend it
right I'm not swooping in
right I'm not swooping in and I'm not
taking the credit and and we give people
control and this is a huge mistake
that's made in leadership all the time
which is all the all the authority sits
at the top all the information set to
the bottom this is David Marquez work
and many falsely believe we have to push
information up so but decisions can be
made which is if inefficient and it
never really happens
but the real responsibility is to push
Authority down and I go back to the
Marine Corps you know commander's intent
the company wants to go in this
direction and we would like to
accomplish this how would you like to
solve that problem like customer service
I mean take something really basic you
know
um which I find fascinating the number
of senior Executives who sit in a room
to fix a customer service problem and
yet why are there no Frontline employees
in that room because there's one group
of people who knows much more about
customer service than anybody else in
the company it's the people who talk to
the customers every day
we're gonna uh get into some questions
um
because I have the mic I'll ask the
first question as a member of the audio
but um so
this is this is one of those ones that I
you know is uncomfortable but um you
know power control has got a new word in
the last uh two years 18 months that I'd
never had not heard prior to that but
it's it's not control it's it's
privilege yep so you have come you know
I I'm among the most privileged people
in ever that lived on Earth and and I
know that and I you know it's made me
think about that very differently but
you know you've seen this event of
privilege happen you know I've I've sat
there we did this on Zoom it was so
weird that we couldn't do this in person
but you know the social events were
happening and
we realize we need to listen we need to
we need to talk there's something going
on here and it's not something going on
it's just there's been a lot that has
not been said
that's always been there yep and I'm
gonna hear it now and and there's this
discontent with I don't like the facts
or it's unfair
that
you're in control it's not just me I
mean it's all basically everyone in this
room is privileged above the average
person in the world yep
um what is privilege what is what does
that whole thing mean to you and how do
we how do we deal with it I mean
you kind of can't help it you're in the
role you can't just like not be in the
role anymore and do your job but
so what what it goes back to feelings of
control of course
um and uh what it what it requires is
empathy the the correct response is
empathy right
um uh uh
and the sort of excessive apologizing
like to apologize for how you were born
is a strange reaction but the most
important thing I think is empathy to
try to understand
uh to try and uh uh relate
um and we saw this happen uh it it
didn't happen unfortunately because we
don't teach the skills we don't teach
active listening we don't teach
Executives or any employee in our
company how to make someone else feel
heard feel understood feel seen
um which is where it starts and if that
can happen then all kinds of trust
builds and and all the other things
start to break away the so for example
when after the murder of George Floyd
I was astonished at the number of uh
people in a leadership position
regardless of you know mid-ranking on on
up
um
did nothing
you mean and the police force or just in
right no no in companies people who
would lead teams that after the murder
of George Floyd they didn't talk to
their teams they just did nothing and
it's not because they're bad people it's
because they didn't have the skills they
didn't know how to have an uncomfortable
or difficult conversation
and so they chose nothing which makes
things worse
and uh and and and this is just a skill
we can teach people and here's how to
have a difficult conversation you bring
your team together and say
um we need to have an uncomfortable
conversation
um about race and our company
and
um uh I'm nervous to have this
conversation
because I'm afraid that I'm I'm going to
Bumble something
I'm afraid that I'm going to say
something that will trigger somebody
and I'm afraid I'm gonna say something
or someone will say something that that
may agitate and make this worse but I
think it's more important that we have
this conversation than we than than my
fear of doing this perfectly
and that's how you start a difficult
conversation and it is difficult
but it is necessary and those
conversations are not happening
and again not because of bad people it's
because people are afraid and they don't
have the skills to start those
conversations and it is the
responsibility of leaders because that's
what we call you leader we call you
leader because you go first not because
you're in charge but because you go
first first to the unknown first to the
difficult first of the dangers
um and it is our responsibility as as as
uh as a corporation to empower and
educate our leaders to to do the things
that they need to do with their teams
um and of course up on high same thing
um so I think that's where it begins
there's a there's a tremendous lack of
listening in our nation yeah
um uh and a lot of talking a lot of
yelling very little listening and
hopefully you know going you know get
past the Omicron wave which you know I
heard this morning in Europe is horrible
and hopefully it will be less
less symptomatic than than before and
we'll be able to get physically back
together which will which will make that
better but if we could um possibly bring
the lights up just a smidge and um if
there's a we've got 15 or so minutes but
we'll take as much time as we want
there's a hand here in the middle
good morning thank you so much for being
here today thank you thank you for
bringing um Mr cynic Simon Simon sorry
um
I'm struck by this last exchange
compared to the earlier discussion of
command and control yeah and Alex's
point about people getting vaccinated
right that seems like an opportunity for
command and control
but there's the need for empathy and
listening 100 how do you balance that so
the decisions we make are not
um disconnected from our need to be
human right which is it is amazing so so
listening is a trust building exercise
right if you've if you're in a take it
down to a personal relationship if
you've been in if you've ever had a
romantic relationship it's a loved one
right
um
um making someone feel heard
doesn't mean you're wrong saying sorry
doesn't mean you're wrong it just means
you take accountability for your for
your actions and I think it is important
that when somebody objects to
vaccination that we don't demonize or
villainize them but we attempt to
hear them make them feel heard doesn't
mean we have to agree but they have to
feel heard and you know
listening is not hearing the words
you know it's making the other person
feel that they were heard it's it's it
we don't get to decide when when hearing
has happened when listening except they
do and and by the way it's not 100
successful either you know because some
people are just hell-bent on and but
that's a minority
and so I think the exercise is sitting
down with people and say tell me tell me
what's what you're going through tell me
what you're afraid of I want to
understand because we're trying to make
everyone safe I I wanna I wanna hear
what what your thing is and let them
tell their story we have no answers
we're not there to object we're not
there to react we're not there to fix or
tell them that they're wrong women are
better than this than men
um uh uh
uh uh
and I think that has to happen and it
can happen simultaneously they're not
mutually exclusive
um I'll give you one one example
which is I have a friend who uh
refuse to get vaccinated
and I sat down with her and I said
tell me tell me your reasoning right
she goes well
um this new technology like I don't
wanna we don't know it hasn't been out
long enough like we don't know so what I
hear is fear of the unknown
okay I go go on and she I let her talk
and say her thing and explain all the
things and I and then and I simply said
so you're afraid of the MRNA technology
right yes and I want them screwing with
my DNA
I said well just so you know it's 20
year old technology but then I found
something I could agree with her but but
you're right
it is the first time it's been
commercialized you're absolutely right
that's the first time we've put it in
the market so I affirmed her fear
and then I said do you get flu shots
every year she goes I do I said okay
Johnson and Johnson is a good
old-fashioned flu shot it's a different
technology it's not mRNA so I you're 100
right if you're afraid of of the new
technology don't get modern or Pfizer
but Johnson and Johnson is it's just
like a flu shot it's the same old Tech
and she went it is when it is she went
and got a modern shot
foreign
because she just wanted to be heard
because most of her friends when she
said I'm not getting vaccinated he
yelled at her told her she was stupid
told her she's an idiot told her she's
letting her friends down told her she's
making other people sick told her she's
a risk to society
that doesn't make somebody's mind open
up all I did was let her feel heard
I think we do we can't we have to do
that
we have to do that we did a interview
recently with a doctor head of
epidemiology at Emory that's we're I
think sending out today or tomorrow but
he said it calling it a mandate
has a much different effect on an
organization than calling it a
requirement an office requirement and uh
it's just how it's how it is taken and
the it can be taken offensively
um
other questions
Percy got one here coming back there
um first of all shout out to all of our
leaders in this room who did an
incredible job managing through and are
doing incredible job managing managing
through the Mandate you guys are amazing
um but Simon you're so much of what you
said really resonated with me as
somebody who previously worked at a
company where at one point we they
implemented a GE performance Force
ranking system
um that was very destructive in the end
um what are your thoughts on income
inequality and how to address you know
the Gap in pay that we see that has just
exploded between between CEOs and median
income yeah because I think that is part
of this finite
yeah you're 100 right and I've forgotten
the exact numbers but I'm not far off
but over the past whatever it is 30 40
years the average CEO pay has increased
something like 750 percent and the
average employee has increased about 11
I mean so it's disproportionate and
nobody Minds that senior Executives will
be better compensated
um but they want to share in the wealth
that they're helping to generate
um and income inequality is one of those
things that makes people feel out of
control because they don't get to
determine their own income you know
um uh uh and so again it's it's not it's
not the it's not that somebody makes
more that's the issue it's the are you
letting me join in
in the success that I am helping to
produce
um do I have opportunities to increase
my own uh wealth like you do you know
you hit certain numbers for example
um uh so I think income inequality in
this country uh I think it's only the
tip of the iceberg and I think it's a
and I think it is uh it is one of those
things that has caused a group of people
to feel disenfranchised in the nation
and
um they've largely their voices have
largely been ignored for 30 30 years and
it's coming to roost and by the way you
can look through history whenever the
the Delta between the Haves and the
have-nots grows too big usually there's
a revolution
I don't know if anybody or I don't know
if you've ever you're a Storyteller Have
you listened to any of Hardcore History
Dan Carlin it's this podcast it is
unbelievable but he gets in he does a
lot of series on the Romans and the
lessons learned and the Gauls and the
Celts and all that stuff and
that hierarchy and yeah it brings down
Empires it does and and unfortunately
there's a lot of similarities between
what America is going through right now
in the Roman Empire but that's a
different company
Percy yeah Simon thanks for being with
us today so I love the comment about
balance so how do we fix the political
landscape
simple stuff thank you uh
you know
uh
a change starts at home
I I you know saying that the politicians
have to change like everybody knows that
but they're not going to because they
have become more finite minded which is
an election is a finite game there's a
beginner there's a beginning middle and
end and there's a winner and there's a
loser but the minute you win your
election now governance is an infinite
game but the problem is they don't make
that conversion and and it used to be it
used to be and I talked to um some
Congressman about this some Old-Timers
and they were explaining to me that back
in the day
80 of the negotiations will be done
behind closed doors and the last 20 was
for the cameras and now it's 100 for the
cameras
and uh in the back in the day the goal
was that each party could go back to
their constituents and say we won and
they could go both go back and say we
got what we wanted and appease their
constituents now it's not enough to say
we won we also have to demonstrate the
other side lost which is a finite
mindset in an infinite game which
decreases trust cooperation and
um uh and but if if we want to go
backwards and look to the root I think
that contract for America
back in the day uh one of the one of the
components of that and but this is not
political I I don't care about the
politics of it but there was a component
of it that said to Congressman no longer
don't move your family to Washington
when you get elected stay home in your
constituency so now what happens is you
have congressmen come to work for about
three days in Washington then fly home
and they're not meeting their
constituents they're fundraising for for
five days a week right but the problem
is back in the day
they fought and they disagreed and they
hated each other but
they sat in the bleachers together to
watch their kids play baseball and they
went to the same PTA meetings and they
were friends and they socialized and
it's really easy to compromise with a
friend and you could sit back and be
like I can't do that you know I can't do
that you know but now there's no
friendships they don't know each other
they sleep on their couches at work and
they only know the people they hang out
with which is their own party we don't
want to go into gerrymandering as well
you know we used to live in a world
where you know we picked our electors
now our electors pick us
um and so they don't work they don't
have Blended
um uh districts anymore where they have
to have a point of view that appeals to
both sides they've they've both sides
have gerrymandered the point they only
have to appeal to your own so they've
both gone more extremists
um but to answer your question directly
without you know I'm sorry I had to go
on the little diatribe but the to answer
your question more directly I think our
politicians are a reflection of us
I think we get what we deserve and this
is none of this is a surprise and none
of this is an anomaly it's all been a
steady drum beat if we just go back 40
years you can see the steady drum beat
to Republican and Democrat
the steady jumping towards more and more
finite and it's just come to a head
these days it's been getting worse for
decades
uh since basically the fall of the
Berlin Wall you can go back to about
1989.
um where that where it started and and
and we are the ones who are complaining
they need to compromise they need to
listen they need to work across the
aisle they need to stop being less
judgmental well hello we need to
compromise we need to listen we need to
work across the aisle we need to be less
judgmental it's us and I think change
always starts at home I've recently um
we have we have a pack and we try to
find moderate nice people that are
willing to have conversations on both
sides and and um uh Senator masto
um chair of the Senate uh Campaign
Committee was with us in our office and
I said I asked this question and she
said
um
there's what you what you don't see is
that we actually do have a lot of
bipartisan work going on we I mean to
get anything done we get into the room
we get both sides of the committee we
talk we see if we can go find some agree
some agreeing votes we come back
together and say the problems we're
facing but we're the goal is to do the
thing to to accomplish something there's
these big iconic
um you know votes on you know voting or
reconciliating or whatever that you know
compeller high water we won't but that's
those are just things you hear about the
things you don't hear about are just
hundreds of laws that get passed all the
time that we we work on together but
when we go back to our constituencies
you say I'm I I said no and you tell
your constituencies how divisive you
were and uh you don't mind all
okay I mean that's that's the same to me
what that's the same party line as well
most cops are good cops you know it's
like yeah I I know that but you have a
problem it's like yeah sure you're very
good at getting the mundane stuff done
Kudos that sounds like table Stakes to
me you know it's like it's the difficult
stuff that the stuff that has to get
done like the fact that we even came to
another Brink where there that
government could get shut down is just
an embarrassment so I you know you know
to me it's it's it's it's a moral
equivalency you know it's that kind of
thing was like well you know like you're
looking at all the bad things like well
but we do a lot of good things it's like
you know
you know last time we'll give to her
yeah so
I don't know I I I I I hear what you're
saying her point was though that it's
it's um it's like you said you're you're
being um you get what you deserve
they don't want to tell they don't want
to say we're playing along publicly
because their voters won't vote for them
because we we are we are a divided
nation and we come from different places
and we we are un we don't trust the
other side and so we're fighting and we
like people
that that fight for us you know when did
compromise become dirty like you cannot
have a successful marriage without
compromise you know you cannot be a
successful person unless the view your
views change as you get older and wiser
right it's only in politics where you
have to believe the same thing for 30
years otherwise you're a bad person it's
only in politics where talking to the
side and trying to find common ground is
considered is considered the devil's
work
um and uh I I just I just I call Bullen
and I've worked with I've worked with
both sides because I preach
bipartisanships I won't I won't work
with a candidate but I'll work with
parties and I've worked with both
parties and I can tell you some funny
stories
um and I've had private conversations
and I'll tell you one of them
so I sat down with a congressman just me
and the congressman no no staffers
around us and and and I had the
uncomfortable conversation which I
wouldn't have publicly with them because
uh it's just inappropriate and I said
you know what your problem is
is you're not willing to sacrifice for
this country
I said I know men and women who wear a
uniform who would lay down their lives
for this country and you won't even give
up your job for this country oh and by
the way if you lost your election you're
going to become a lobbyist or some
consultant and you'll make more money
than you've ever dreamed of so my
question is what exactly are you losing
whether you keep your job or lose your
job the answer is nothing power
and uh right and but the point is that
they're in a win-win situation I'm
either powerful or I got cash like
that's your choice
um and he looked at me and said you're
right none of us are none of us are
willing to and this is not what our
finding fathers intended our finding
fathers intended that you would leave
your law practice you would leave your
farm you'd come and serve your nation
for a a a a few uh
um
uh Cycles
uh and then you go back to your career
we have professional politicians now
people who've been in office for 30
years they actually don't know how to do
anything else take anybody who's been
doing something for 30 years and say
you're going to stop doing it and fear
is the motivation as well we I finally
found has never wanted a class of
professional politician that was never
in the in in the design of this nation
um so I I think there's there's um my my
this is a horrible thought but it's a
thought that I've struggled with
for years now and I and I cannot
reconcile it which is
um we we lost something when the Berlin
Wall came down which is we lost an
external existential threat
we always fought we always disagreed but
at the end of the day we could come
together and say
that's not that that threatens all of us
and so we could come together
in defense of of our of our beliefs in
our nation and when the Berlin Wall came
down and we lost uh a perception because
it still exists we just lost the
perception of the external existential
threat what happens it's a weird Quirk
of humanity which is vision and positive
stuff and all this stuff is all ethereal
but negative stuff is usually tangible
and so it's a weird Quirk of humanity
that it's that it's that I can more
easily Define what I stand for when I
can see what I stand against
but if that thing that I stand against
doesn't exist then it's very hard for me
to articulate what I stand for and so I
look for something that I'm against to
help me understand what I stand for and
so if it doesn't exist outside our
borders I'm gonna look inside our
borders and we start to see a massive
increase of infighting inside our nation
because we don't have any sense that
there's something threatening us as a
tribe
um
so you've got this conundrum I don't
know if there's others that by the way
was also part of the Roman Empire after
Carthage was flattened which was their
Soviet Union
um Rome went into steep decline because
of infighting yeah so we've got this
conundrum where you know where we have
these goals we're trying to get things
done there's the
are you saying that we should stop
thinking about our goals and think about
what if you if you kind of transform
your mind into the infinite are you
thinking why are we really here is that
is that what we should do as Leaders
when you're thinking about vaccines and
mandates and privilege and all these
tricky things it's not about abandoning
goals it's contextualizing the goals and
what most businesses lack is context for
the goals so we use all the wrong
analogies in business we use War
analogies it's a launch it's a campaign
you know we use uh Sports analogies you
know uh it's it's Fourth and goal and
like we've got a and and they're all
finite constructions
um we need to start thinking of business
like a lifestyle right think of it more
like Health like I want to be healthy
what does it take to be healthy well you
have to exercise you have to eat right
you have to nurse your personal
relationships you have to have enough
sleep there's probably 30 other things
you can't do all of these things
perfectly all the time it's a striving
well what you have to do well in
business you need good products you need
good service you need good leadership
so you can't do all those things
perfectly all the time it's a striving
and you can absolutely have arbitrary
goals in that we love a metric human
beings love a metric so for example I
want to lose x amount of weight by X
date arbitrary number arbitrary date
which is largely how we pick financial
goals we're going to hit this goal by
this date
make it this number you know
um
uh
uh and it's arbitrary
and that's fine
and so you go and you stand on the scale
every morning you're doing all the right
things we love measuring we love
counting we love feeling the progress
and then you hit your goal and
you're ecstatic but here's the thing you
have to keep exercising for the rest of
your life it doesn't end and it's the
same with business you hit your goal but
the whole thing called business and all
that striving and marketing and it it
doesn't end like you have to keep doing
it but I think it's more interesting
when we miss the goal
because if you're doing all this stuff
and you stand on the scale on that day
and you miss your goal you know what
happens you keep working out nothing
happened
right and what's more important is the
trend
because you are more healthy now you're
healthier now than you were when you
started you just happened to pick the
wrong date clearly you're going to hit
it in a month
and I think what we as companies need to
start doing is first of all
contextualizing the goal the reason we
need to hit this goal is because it
helps us build towards that bigger
Vision yeah and
when we hit it we look at the context do
we have bad leadership that just you
know at the last minute in the last
quarter had all these promotions so they
could hit their numbers but they're a
terrible leader building a terrible team
and this has been their year
but we bonus that person versus the
other team that's really well LED that's
doing everything right beautiful steady
growth line they just happen to miss the
number we give them nothing so we're
accidentally incentivizing the wrong
behaviors I think we need to start
looking at Trend data because that's
infinite mindedness and I think we need
to start contextualizing those goals if
they lack context if it's goal for the
point of goal you're in a finite game
I'm going to use your um your leadership
example here we have a finite amount of
time that now is blinking red and
um but I don't care because we're on a
roll you know so
thank you
and I saw I saw somebody they're raising
their hand in a moment of high stress we
use command and control
so we'll take one last question
yes yes go ahead
hi
Sandra Davis first Forum new to Cox now
first form ninja Cox actually came from
um one of the companies you described a
Jack Welch type company Globe is a big
blue Globe is a logo whatever the case
is welcome thank you thank you thank you
I am just um you know so taken aback by
this experience as a woman and a woman
of color I'm struck by your comments on
momentum versus sort of finite goals and
I think part of the reason I'm here is
because of Cox's commitment to diversity
action speak Etc was really important
for me as I looked to leave in the
opening
um it was said that you advise Alex and
so I'm interested in how or if you're
advising him on maintaining this
momentum that Cox has from an action
speaks perspective to make sure that you
know what we're seeing with you know
movement with women and people of color
selfishly is not a finite goal that we
achieve and we go back right but that we
continue with this momentum so I'm
interested in how you would advise
someone sure
so candidly Alex and I haven't talked
for a long time there's a little reunion
for us too which is fun
um but I but I can I can address it
which is uh
when we treat
Dei
like a finite goal
which I think unfortunately too many
companies are
um and uh he here's the here's the
uncomfortable reality of all of this
stuff right which is to truly make
Improvement and fix things
or at least improve things
um it's a it's a steady sometimes slow
process it's like rebuilding trust in a
relationship it doesn't happen with one
bouquet of flowers and a really nicely
written card even if it's really
heartfelt and important and necessary
it's it's consistency and ongoing right
but at the same time we need to see
gestures so that we can see remember we
love a metric we love to see that
something's happening but we see it all
over the place we see it in police
reform we see it in D I always see a lot
of companies and and communities doing
the short-term stuff for show that may
or may not be having the impact they
need to have I'm okay with the short
time of stuff for show so long as the
difficult slow work is happening behind
the scenes simultaneously right
um and so and and great companies as we
said like like good people they and by
the way there's there's no competitors
in the infinite game because you can't
beat anybody there's only other players
right the only true competitors yourself
how do we become a better version of
yourself today than we were yesterday
and so all of these things you know
George Floyd the murder of George Floyd
forced our nation to hold a mirror up to
ourselves and and just to go as an aside
you know after uh Floyd is murdered I
called
um some of my African-American friends
and I needed advice how to have
difficult conversations I needed I
wanted to hear how they how they were
you know and on some of the
conversations I was crying
and I asked them
though Something's Happened with uh with
all of them I said I'm crying how come
you're not crying and they said because
I'm exhausted they said this is new for
you this is not new for me this is I
live this life you're just seeing it for
the first time because the whole scene
was captured we've been talking about
this but usually you just see the dead
body in the street and we don't see what
led up to it what made George Floyd
important was the camera
that we got to see it
and for for people who haven't seen that
for for all the reasons it was shocking
good
you know
um and so I think that when we talk
about the infinite gaming about a
constant Improvement
you know
blaming some someone for something they
didn't see isn't helpful but now that
they've seen it we say okay let's do
that work and let's go through the
constant Improvement like what are the
things that we can do inside our company
so this is not for show and temporary
and fashionable but this becomes part of
our part of our part of our growth part
of Who We Are
that we become more aware of these
things we have systems in place we have
different kinds of metrics we have
different kinds of incentives we have
different kinds of practices we have
we've implemented things like listening
skills
we've implemented things like teaching
anybody who gets promoted to any
position of leadership to learn how to
have a difficult conversation the
reality is if you can have a difficult
conversation about race you can have a
difficult conversation about anything
your performance is not doing so great
that's a difficult conversation
so I think this is a massive opportunity
like any learning opportunity for
personal growth and companies go through
personal growth like people go through
personal growth and what somebody says
ongoing forever exercise eating right
it's this is forever
this is forever it's a striving and
that's what we have to remember it's a
striving
somebody said something that stuck with
me during all this which was diversion
and inclusion diversity and inclusion
you can have a as diverse of a Workforce
as you want it doesn't make a it doesn't
amount to anything if you don't have an
inclusive culture and it's it's a
mindset and it's not a number and and I
look I got a bunch of phone calls after
uh during right after uh the murder of
George Floyd and I was really annoyed by
how many Executives were more
preoccupied with the press release than
with the hard work they needed to do
inside their company you know I
understand you got to put the press
release out I'm fine with that but it
should be
it should the press release reflect the
work that you're deciding to do it
shouldn't be the priority before the
work you decide to do yeah I'd say
everybody in this room did that and it's
a great it's a great um great question
to end on
gives us plenty to think about I want to
thank you for being with us it has been
too long I do want to take your advice
more and I don't want it to go to be
another four years before we see you so
thank you for joining us and thank you
for what you're doing to add goodness
into the world around us